最近のビデオで、どれだけ
多くの日本人学習者が
日本語のすべての動詞
を特定のアクセントで言う傾向があるかについて話しました.多くの
学習者はこれらの動詞を運び
、ハコブのように演奏すると言い
ました. 動詞は多かれ少なかれ
フラットです。
現在、一部の人々がこのビデオを見
て素晴らしい質問をしました。彼らは大丈夫だと答え
ました。たとえば
、開く動詞やシャワーを浴びる動詞を学習した場合、日本語のどの動詞にアクセントがあり、どの動詞がフラットであるかをどうやって知ること
ができますか 教科書またはアプリを使用して、
これらの動詞にアクセントがあるかフラット
かどうかを知るにはどうすればよいですか? また、アクセントがある場合、アクセントがどこにあるかをよく知るにはどうすればよい
でしょうか? これらの単語
はネイティブ スピーチですが
、ピッチ アクセントを拾うように耳を訓練し
ていない限り、これは実際には
あまり
うまく機能しません。 デュ 日本語の勉強を
もう一度鳴らしてシャワーを浴びる ピッチ牛を勉強したことがない限り
、耳だけに頼っている場合は、通常
、アケルとアビルと間違って発音します。
どちらも間違っています。この閉じる動詞に
はアクセントがあり、多くの人が
これを聞いて、
対応する open にも再びアクセントがあると思い込んでいます
が、これは正しくありません。それは akeru です。
次に、この動詞 to shower もアクセントがあり
ません。abiru では、not です
が、
akeru で
あり、私は個人的にこれらの動詞の両方を to と言い
ました。 シャワーを浴びたり、他の
多くの日常的な日本語の動詞と同様に、
これらの誤ったパッチ アクセント パターンを使用
したり、これらのアクセント付きピッチ アクセント
パターン
を使用
したりします。 あなたは
通常、無意識のうちに日本語のルールで
はなく、母国語のルールに従って遊んでいます.
彼らに高低アクセントを理解してもらうように指示したので
、
日本語の辞書か何らかのアプリケーションを使用して、日本語の
すべての単語のすべての動詞の高高アクセント パターンを調べる
ことができましたが、その方がはるかに効果的です。
代わりに、複数の単語または単語のファミリーのピッチ動作とパターンを
示すいくつかの重要なルールを覚えておく方がはるかに実用的
です。これらのルールの1つは
動詞ルールであり、このルールは非常に役立ちます。
常にアクセントを持っており、この
アクセントは
常に単語の最後から 2 番目のビートで発生します。
保存または維持
するため
に際立っている
言葉のビートは今、あなた
は自分自身によく考えているかもしれ
ませんが、それはそれほど難しいことではあり
ません。たとえ誰も私にそのルールを明示的に教えてくれなかったとしても、とにかくそれらの動詞をそのように言ったでしょう
が、それは
おそらくこれらすべての理由によるものであることを覚えておくことは非常に重要
です. 動詞に
はアクセントがあり、
訓練されていない発音の本能に頼っているだけなら
、私がしたことをやってしまう可能性が高く、
前に見たように、他の
日常的な日本語の動詞と同様に、to open や to shower などのアクセントのない動詞を言うことになります。
洗うの
が好き 触れるの
をやめるの
が好き 踊る
ために使うの
をやめる
など 間違った発音パターン
で 前述の動詞のすべてをもう一度
開く シャワー
を浴びる 洗うの
を
止める 静かに
する 触れる
のをやめて 踊る など
リストは続く これらはすべて
実際に
はアクセントがなく、無意識のうちにアクセントでこれらを言うと、アクセントでこれらを言うと、実際には
無意識のうちにかなり大きな
発音の間違いを犯しています. 誤解しないでください
人々はあなたの言っている
ことを完全に理解しますが、それ
は英語の単語
を間違った音節にアクセントを付けて
言うようなものです 明日もう一度言うのではなく、明日と言うような
ものです 人々はあなたが何であるかを理解するでしょう 言っても
自然に聞こえませんそれは聞こえません
ピッチアクセントについてのことはそれであり、
これは飲み込むのが非常に難しい薬に
なる可能性があります。
訓練されていない
発音の本能に頼るのは少し危険
です。耳を訓練したことがない場合は、自分の耳を単に信頼し、ピッチアクセントの勉強を始めれ
ば、言い換えれ
ば
、聞いているものは何でも完全に再現できると思い込みます。
私はこの発音
が私にとって最も自然に感じられることを知って
おり、私はそれを何ヶ月も、あるいは何年も使用していることを知って
います
が、これは実際には正しい
発音であり、 もちろん、これが
ルールのような
ルールが
、できるだけ自然に聞こえたい人にとって非常に便利な理由です。
なぜなら、
私たちが大丈夫と言うことができるすべての当て推量を取り除くだけ
だからです。私はまだ耳を訓練していることを知っています。
このピッチアクセントの基本をまだ学んでいますが、
これらすべての動詞は
日本語で終わる
すべての動詞がこのように発音されることも知っ
ています。そのため、それらを1つずつ覚える必要はありません。
大きなグループです。 言葉
の邪魔にならないように覚え
て時間を節約し、その時間を使って
、よりトリッキーな動詞
を覚えたり、単一のルールでは覚えられない動詞を覚えたりすることが
できます。  do で終わる
日本語のすべての動詞に
はアクセントがあり、そのアクセント
は動詞の最後から 2 番目のビートにある
ことを覚えておいてください。
このような規則をさらに学びたい場合は、実際には
非常によく一致する規則がもう 1 つあります。
これでそれはess
このルールの有効性を実質的に2倍に
します。以下にリンクされているパトレオンシリーズで、このようなルールをたくさん説明して
いますが、これらの
種類のルールに加え
て、役立つために使用できるいくつかの演習とアンキデッキもあります
日本語の高低アクセントを拾うように耳を訓練し、最終的に
修正して、
ネイティブの本能を乗り越え
ます。自分の母国語から持っている本能な
ので、それが
特定の日本語学習目標に役立つと思われる場合は
、次のリンクがあります。 下の説明
はわかりました。このビデオがお役に立てば幸いです。またお会いしましょう
。